andy jassy will take over for jeff bezos
as the head of amazon on july 5th
27 years to the day after the outgoing
chief executive officer incorporated
amazon.com inc
jassy who currently leads amazon's cloud
computing division amazon web services
will take on the role following a year
in which amazon reported 386 billion
dollars in sales
and hired half a million people he'll
also oversee the integration and
development of entertainment content
after wednesday's announcement that
amazon
purchased film studio mgm for more than
8 billion
but he will have to manage growing
regulatory scrutiny
and calls from shareholders to improve
the company's diversity practices
and impact on civil rights on the
regulatory front
the district of columbia filed an
anti-trust lawsuit against amazon
tuesday
the case alleges that amazon has
prevented sellers in its online
marketplace from charging lower prices
than those available elsewhere
keeping prices and profits high
in a meeting wednesday bezos pointed to
amazon's cloud computing businesses
suggesting that they operate in
competitive industries with other
players that are growing quickly
including twilio and snowflake on the
shareholder front
amazon defeated a series of shareholder
proposals
including one demand that called for the
company to conduct a third party audit
of its impact on civil rights
similar to studies conducted by facebook
and airbnb other proposals
called for audits on the company's
facial recognition software and the
risks of selling it to governments
and a study on amazon's customer due
diligence
executives also sought to address the
demands of its employees
in the past year amazon employees have
attempted to form a union
filed lawsuits alleging discrimination
and retaliation
and called on leadership to bolster
diversity hiring
alicia bowler davis amazon's vice
president for global customer
fulfillment
and the first black woman to join
amazon's small executive branch
said wednesday the company is vowing to
become both earth's best and
safest employer but under jassy who
built amazon's cloud division into a
market leader
the company will need to navigate
increasing scrutiny from government
agencies
and the potential for more activism from
amazon employees
issues that bezos has largely avoided
for almost three decades
[Music]
you